[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
you dirty little trickster
Roger Stone as he's known on the show
start your own
do you remember when the um
The Oath Keepers that are charged with
seditious conspiracy you remember when
they protected him on January 6th do you
remember that
hmm
I want I wonder I wonder if any of that
has to do with anything
Roger Stone is a [__] traitor we know
that
and he's like
honestly he's a cartoon super villain
in the Trump dumpster fire right
have you seen some pictures of this guy
like just normal average every day
life he's a super villain are trying to
look like a super villain a cartoon
super villain at that he's better at
being a super villain
then Jared Leto the Jared Leto Jokers
isn't isn't it the worst one
like don't you think but but really
stodger Roan is more like
the penguin in my opinion right like if
there's uh if there's a a cartoon
villain
that is Dodger roon
then it's then it's probably the penguin
you know no one likes him he's ugly
everyone he's an outcast
that's any anywhere's crazy ass outfits
that's Don gerone
but last night on Ari melber Show on
MSNBC The Beat uh they had an exclusive
video of
stodgerone otherwise known as Roger
Stone basically laying out the state
elector's scheme and coup plot that at
that 19 people have been indicted for in
Georgia and 16 State elect fake State
electors fraudulent State electors have
indicted for Michigan
now this isn't a surprise really
is it yeah were you like whoa holy moly
Roger Stone was plotting a coup
no no one thought that
no one was thinking that
not one not one of you were like wow
that's amazing I never could have saw
that coming yeah okay
and if that's really your thought like
whoa this is crazy
then you haven't been paying attention
to who Roger Stone is
or who Donald Trump is for that matter
I mean really you know you got you got
coup plotters like Jenna Ellis and that
that's hilarious Jenna Ellis right now
oh my God Have You Seen Her begging for
money
begging
because Trump's not gonna pay for her
legal fees because she's supporting
DeSantis
I mean pretty simple terms that's why
Trump is not going to support her
is because she's supporting Santa so
he's not going to pay her legal fees
like he is walty nada and and Carlos
which apparently those two have a
conflict of interest with their
attorneys representing them I guess
there's going to be a conflict hearing
for Walt NADA and and Carlos down at
Mar-A-Lago in the documents case
oh yeah oh yeah and and
the D.A in Fulton County fonnie Willis
request for March
I guess
that's what we're going for is March
for the trial good luck with that I
don't see this thing getting to trial by
March
do you
there's 19 defendants they're probably
going to have at least maybe a third of
those defendants flip which is going to
turn new evidence which is probably
going to bring to light more of the
[__] picture in the story I mean
that's that's generally when you when
you turn evidence and you and you become
a rat normally what you have to do is
give them more to get a deal like
they're not going to give you a deal
unless you give them something
more than likely
so we'll we'll see we'll see if they
they plea out to either turn or just to
plea out just to get a lesser sentence
in a state penitentiary in Georgia which
is probably the last [__] prison that
you ever want to be in is a goddamn
State pen in Georgia
but the Saga ticks on and we find out
that oh yeah okay Roger Stone was an
integral part of
planning this coup plot so where is
Roger Stone part of the 30 unindicted
co-conspirators
in Georgia
is he is he one of them
and why isn't he indicted
did he did he give them his documentary
footage
again this is really stupid this is this
is why they're nincompoop Nazis right
Roger Stone has a has a document a
documentary crew following him around
literally recording him in real time
plotting a coup for Donald Trump to
overthrow the government in our vote in
our election
in real time
he's like yeah come on record me
committing [__] crime let's do that
this only speaks to that they really
thought they were gonna do it
Rogers Roger Stone knows knows when he's
committing crime
he knows it
Roger Stone's not stupid I mean he's
[__] weird he's eccentric and he is a
cartoon villain
but he's not stupid he knows when he's
committing crime that's what the whole
mob thing is that's the whole [__]
when you talk around you're like well I
I didn't say you know that kind of [__]
you know I'm talking about
it's why they have Rico charges in the
first place and they caught him in
Georgia
is because you're trying to act like
[__] mob bosses and they're not good
at it because you're recording it no
[__] mob boss is gonna record
themselves
[__] committing crime
they're not listen Mobsters aren't going
to go to the Capitol and live stream
themselves committing violence
like the January 6 insurrectionist
they're not the [__] toothless
rednecks are on Facebook streaming
themselves hey look I'm at the Capitol
committing Federal felonies I'm gonna
try to overturn the government yeah okay
but see how that works out for you they
[__] around and found out
now Roger Stone
of course we knew this because there's
been Clips before of him saying crazy
ass [__] to this to this film crew
we've we've even shown on the show here
with the with the film crew that was
following around Stuart Rhodes and
Enrique tario where they met in the
parking garage these people are [__]
dumb
but the thing that is this proves is
they really really thought that they're
not the baddies
they thought they were gonna overturn
this election Trump was going to be king
and everything was going to be good and
they'd be safe and they'd be the heroes
of History
I think that's the [__] wildest part
about the whole thing
that Roger Stone looks at himself in the
mirror and he sees a super villain he
sees the infamous Roger Stone
who one day could overturn American
democracy
so that he can make it his little play
toy
you think that's how he laughs in the
mirror when he looks himself
like after he brushes his teeth if he
brushes his teeth I don't I don't know
if Roger Stone brushes his teeth I have
no [__] clue he may or may not I
don't know
but after he brushes his teeth he's like
he's practicing his laugh
[Laughter]
do you think that's what he does
I don't know he's always doing the Nixon
thing you know he's got a tattoo of
Nixon
in between the shoulder blades you know
that have tattoo of Nixon's face
or do you think Trump said you think
Trump's on his ass Trump's face is on
his ass I don't know I I don't know I
don't know
I have no idea
all I'm saying is is that I bet Roger
Stone practices his evil laughs
oh man I'm so glad to have you guys here
on this Thursday Thursday it's it's
treasonous Thursday with Roger Stone
today we're gonna play this clip for you
and I'm gonna play several other Roger
Stone Clips today to show you and this
is not surprising that he's recording
himself committing federal crimes this
is not it should not be out of the
ordinary
I'm I'm glad I'm so glad you're joining
us we've had record audiences lately so
to all the new listeners I want to tell
you remind you to subscribe right here
on YouTube hit the Subscribe button it
is free also if you like the broadcast
hit the thumbs up
and if you don't whatever hit the thumbs
down leave a comment
why not why not and if you love the chat
speaking of the chat if you love the
chat you gotta go over to Discord this
is where the chat party never stops over
there on Discord it's growing growing
growing like crazy over there I'm gonna
throw the uh the link here in the
in the chat so you can find the Discord
that way you guys can go over to the
Discord server where the chat never
stops
it's a chat party and it don't stop over
there on Discord they do all kinds of
cool stuff they're streaming videos and
playing music that you can post your
favorite memes there you can go collect
memes if you're looking for the best
political means go over to the Discord
server they got a whole [__] there's
a whole goddamn chat room with nothing
but [__] memes in it so if you're
looking for your memes that you need to
put out on social media they're all
right there cataloged yeah on the
Discord server so go over to Discord
where the chat never stops and you can
get some uh gets get your get your film
memes also you can watch us on Facebook
and twitch twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels don't forget to follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod we're gonna
vote for bonehead of the week
that's right we're gonna vote for
bonehead of the Week Tonight uh
tomorrow's Friday Friday Friday and you
know what happens on Friday here on the
show in the second hour of the show
in the second hour of the show you vote
you decide who is the bonehead of the
week and me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez
breaks it down every single Friday with
bonehead of the week so be watching for
that poll
I've got a venmo chat coming in here uh
just a few seconds ago so let me let me
pull that up on the screen do you guys
know about the venmo chat you know
YouTube doesn't like me so they won't
let me monetize so I was like ah [__]
we're gonna find a work around here a
lot of people like the super chats they
like to give money and give the super
chats and bring their chat up on the uh
on the screen there so we're doing venmo
chat since YouTube doesn't like me uh
you can just go to venmo chat but here
let me give you the link so you can go
to the venmo chat you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
and you can find the venmo chat there at
the very top uh if you want to send a
venmo chat here's how it works you just
send a venmo chat you can put your
YouTube handle or your Facebook handle
or whatever whatever handle you're
you're wanting me to talk to you from if
you don't put your hand open
it'll just be anonymous I guess
but uh
here I'm gonna pull up this uh this
recent one from Stephanie now Stephanie
sent us this chat here
well let's see what she what Stephanie
has to say here
okay she says that I discovered you on
Tick Tock you need to stay current on
Tick Tock ah she see she's saying hey
post more Tick Tock videos Tony please
make more your videos available on Tick
Tock gen Z is completely engaged don't
miss out on this thank you so much for
your daily I think she's mean Daily Show
yeah I need to post more tick tocks I
got all well I didn't get off Tick Tock
I just I don't know I lost interest in
Tick Tock and and the reason why is
because Tick Tock is such a [__] with
my content like they'll ban me and then
I'm I can't post anything and and then
and then they Shadow ban me and so I
post something it's like 12 views or
some [__] and then they've shot they
turn my videos off because someone
reports them it's a [__] [__] it's a
more of a [__] than YouTube to be quite
honest with you Tick Tock is so that's
one reason why I don't post as much as I
used to on Tick Tock but you know what
you're right you're right Stephanie I
should post more on Tick Tock uh we'll
try to get some clips going and uh post
some more Clips on Tic Tac because you
know we need the exposure for Gen Z we
need more people to see this show the
more people that watch this show the
better well off we are so thank you
Stephanie for your
your venmo chat there again you can send
me a message on venmo chat you can use
the the little the little barcode thing
or the QR code there on the screen or
you can go to the Tony michaels.com the
link is right there
or it's in the chat here so you can you
can do that you can give me hit me up
there
okay so I want to talk about
um Hawaii uh for a minute uh there's
been a lot of stuff happening in Hawaii
with this this fire apparently they have
not found uh the cause of the fire yet I
believe the reports were that there was
81 mile an hour winds when this fire was
going the fire was so hot it got up to
almost 800 Degrees and this fire was
moving at a mile a minute and I don't
know if you know how fast a mile a
minute is but that is extremely fast for
a fire to move
um these I guess there's still over a
thousand missing uh this morning I think
that they're they're confirmed death
toll is 114. people are left with
absolutely nothing and some just with
the clothes on their back if they were
lucky to have that I watched the video
of people trying to escape the island in
a car it was so hot they were burning up
inside the car that's how hot it was uh
on that island now there's a lot of
conspiracy theories the right is using
this to their advantage to their
narrative that's why I want to speak on
it right now uh and the reason why I've
never been to Hawaii I would love to go
um and so
uh but does see the pictures uh from the
island there devastated by the fire it's
devastating it didn't matter what
American town that would be rather it's
on the island of Maui or it would be in
California or Tennessee or Missouri
Alabama New York where wherever wherever
those fires would be
um to devil State communities like that
not just the devastate communities but
to uh to kill possibly hundreds maybe a
thousand people in a matter of moments
uh is is devastating and of course the
scumbags on the right are trying to jump
on the train and use this to their
advantage they're spinning conspiracy
theories had the fire start why isn't
Joe Biden doing more which he's deployed
the entire federal government with FEMA
there
so they're going to get their funds
they're going to get their cleanup but
it's happened so fast and the way that
the fire burned everything there's so
much danger with toxins and everything
and and then their main priority is to
look for people's loved ones if there's
anyone still alive uh in the aftermath
of course the right wing the right wing
always takes advantage of these things
they always spend their stupid little
[__] conspiracy theories you know it
reminds me when there's a mass shooting
and the country goes why aren't we
[__] doing anything about this
uh the one of the prominent ones that
come to mind
is at the Covenant School there in
Tennessee
when
in a Christian conservative School
there was a shooting someone gunned down
people in a school
and Democratic lawmakers there the
Justins
Justin Jones Justin Pearson
uh stood up and said we're not going to
take this anymore I don't care who who
it is our state is our state it's our
community it doesn't matter who's
getting gunned down we're going to stand
against it
they didn't care who got shot they
didn't give a [__]
their activism is is not is not
selective
of who it affects
Justin Pearson and Justin Jones are
fighting we're fighting at the moment in
that moment
to end gun violence they didn't give a
[__] who it was against
they didn't give a [__] and you know
what so much so that they went to the
floor
broke the rules for like 30 seconds and
they ex they voted to expel them they
didn't vote to expel Gloria Johnson the
white woman who went to the floor with
them
they didn't expel her
now since then uh Justin Pearson Justin
Jones were reseeded by votes of their
Council and have won their special
elections
which is not surprising and the reason
why is because they have [__]
principles
and that's the difference and you can
see it you can see it from the
narratives from Hawaii
listen we don't know the exact reason of
the fire apparently they are getting
footage from security cams of how fast
this fire was moving because of the wind
but it was dry
the wind was coming
they had a windstorm coming a wind event
coming on the island something sparked
the fire they don't know what yet but
with that amount of wind and and how dry
it was on the island of course of course
there was going to if there was a spark
there would be a fire and there was a
fire it was going to be just a
hellacious event
but the spin the conspiracy theories
that somehow this is so it's a
distraction or some Q Anon space laser
type [__]
these are the [__] scumbags that we
are fighting against
and I know you know you're you're
probably like Tony you can always make
something political it's not me it's not
me making it [__] political
I haven't hardly spoke on on the Maui
Island fire and the reason why is
because I don't have the [__] facts
yet
the only facts I have gathered is yes it
was a devastating fire
it was moving very quickly because
there's a wind event and it's likely
that it killed hundreds maybe even over
a thousand people on that island in a
matter of minutes
that's what I have at my disposal
they're still looking for why why it
started how it started and where it
started they may never really truly know
but that doesn't mean that it's some
kind of blood-sucking cabal
coop plot or conspiracy theory
these [__] scumbags do this every
time
every single [__] time
and that's why when there is a mass
shooting and people are like let's put
it in like Justin Pearson and Justin
Jones use their voices that their
constituents gave them duly elected
officials
to use their voices
to call for all gun violence to stop not
just the gun violence that they don't
that they want stopped
and they say oh it's now's not a time to
politicize this issue the [__] out of
here the reason why they're saying that
is because they always politicize an
issue it doesn't matter even if it's
political or not
this fire in Hawaii has nothing to do
with politics
other than other than this we should
make sure to elect competent officials
to handle disasters like this that
period
period And if you think electing a bunch
of conspiracy theorists Republicans who
are only interested in [__] exposing
pictures of Hunter Biden's dick are
people who are serious enough to take
care of a [__] natural disaster like
this you are [__] out of your mind
you're out of your [__] mind
and just like the Jason Aldean thing I
thought you know what I'm I'm not gonna
talk about the Maui thing and the reason
why is because I really don't have the
facts yet we don't know yet
we just don't know what we don't know
and until we do I don't want to
postulate certain things but now I I'm
forced to I'm forced to again because
the [__] chuckleheads on the right
these nincompoop Nazis
continuing to to just few [__]
conspiracy theories when they don't know
that's why I tell you every single day
this threat is at our doorstep it is
here and it is now
we cannot let up we have to be vigilant
against these [__] fools
and that's what they are they are
[__] fools they're cowards
they're easy to fight if you're willing
to fight them look at Roger Stone what
the [__] are you serious are you serious
you you were so confident that you were
gonna overthrow our vote
you were you you totally underestimated
the American resolve of of Freedom
Liberty and democracy Roger
you little [__] [__]
what a piece of trash Roger Stone is
piece of American [__] garbage he is
isn't it sad isn't it sad that we have
to look at some of our countrymen and
just be in total discuss of how much of
a treasonous treacherous
just absolute piece of trash they are
[__] him
and [__] anyone like him like this
[__] lady down in where was it Alvin
Texas is that where this [__] is from
Abigail
Abby Abby Joe schreier or whatever the
[__] her name is threaten to kill judge
chuckin because judge chutkin drew the
straw to be the judge she's a 95-0 voted
judge confirmed
95-0 in the Senate
she's not some sort of deep state plant
and if she is all the [__]
Republicans that voted for her are deep
Staters we need to call them out too I
guess if you're gonna call out the Deep
state
it's [__] ridiculous it's
anti-American it's unpatriotic
and they should [__] lock her up
every single day they possibly can [__]
her just like Craig Robertson got what
he [__] around doing he found the [__]
out
it's enough of this [__] terrorist
[__] these domestic terrorists calling
and making threats then veiled threats
lock her lock her up [__] her
every [__] day that judge can give
her give it to her every single last one
of them
no [__] Mercy it's enough of this
[__] these people have had plenty of
time to see that your [__] orange
Mussolini Jesus is a God damn loser
and when you support him not only when
you support him
but when you commit crime for him you go
to jail
so enough of the domestic terrorist [__]
and again I'm tired of hearing their
conspiracy theories about a fire and
about how Joe Biden isn't doing enough
for Hawaii get the [__] out of here
listen they're still looking for bodies
if there's bodies that exist you
right-wing [__] chuds
they're still looking for people's
bodies they're probably gonna have to
use DNA to identify some of the ashes
and charred bone that is left
you [__] insensitive pricks
and you think Joe Biden's gonna go
around and just traips around
trance around on their graves and throw
paper towels at them get the [__] out of
here with that nonsense
there is not one goddamn reason where
the president United States has to have
his feet on Hawaii at this point
not one
all he needs to do is deploy the experts
deploy the Manpower make sure that
Hawaii has exactly what they need in the
moment that they need it
and right now their search and rescue
effort is ongoing and it is at the
Forefront and trying to take care of
those folks that are in an on the ground
that have lost everything and the people
helping them look for their loved ones
you dumb [__]
don't yeah I I really I really thought I
really thought that there was at least
just a little bit just a little bit of
humanity left in these [__] but
there's not
they won't even take a second to
understand exactly what happened in
Hawaii no matter how it happened what
happened
they're absolute dog [__] every [__]
last one of them
and some of them are people that you
know personally it's sad but it's true
your family members maybe your old
classmates maybe people you work with
people you used to respect
but it's gotten to a place in this
country where people like Roger Stone
are idols
Idols he's he's on videotape
plotting to overthrow our democracy
not just once several times
and this I bet this Abby Joe schreier
whatever the hell her name is down in
Alvin Texas oh I bet you she loves some
Roger Stone
doubt me
because the quote was to chetkin that
they were gonna take her life if if
Trump didn't get elected as if chutkin
has the option of trump getting elected
it's insanity
sanity
we've lost our [__] minds and
honestly we need to elect some serious
people to get some mental health care in
this country [__] fast like really
[__] fast like you know I always talk
about you know you shouldn't go broke
because of a medical bill but you
shouldn't have to go to prison because
you got a [__] mental illness because
you can't get mental health care and you
get [__] deluded by Facebook and Q
Anon and and send death threats to
federal judges
there you go there's you an issue to
[__]
try to work out in Congress good [__]
Lord
hell
boy Robert has sent us another venmo
chat here venmo chat thank you Robert
again if you want to put your um if you
want to put your handle uh in in the uh
in the venmo chat when you send it
you know what I mean you know what I
mean burn uh he says just heard Trump is
offering an apprenticeship for his
prison spray Tanner
uh Robert Robert H
apparently uh Trump's sending out a memo
Trump's Indiana memory just heard Trump
is offering an apprenticeship for his
prison spray Tanner thank you Robert for
the uh
for the venmo chat again if you want to
do a venmo chat there's the QR code on
the screen you go to the Tony
michaels.com the link is there or you
can find the link in the chat here I'll
post it again if you want to if you want
to get a lot of people like the Super
Chat thing so I was like how can we do
this so I'm doing venmo
oh no never mind that was that's
Robert's statement see what I mean
oh boy I got the wrong one in in
[Applause]
and there it is again this is not
working all right well we'll go to a
break when we come back we'll put the
venmo chat the memo Link in the chat
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
again is this really is this um is this
a big surprise it's not a surprise to me
this is a surprise to you
that he is that he was one of the main
coup plotter I mean we knew this again I
spoke about it for for a long time we
had we had Stuart Rhodes's son on Dakota
Adams several times talking about how
The Oath Keepers would work and how
their security would work and if you go
back and you rewind back to the
beginning of January in 2021 uh when
they when they were when they were
preparing uh for the January 6
Insurrection because that's what they
were preparing for Stuart Rhodes and
Ricky tario met in a parking garage they
were trying to plot out what their roles
were going to be we know that through
all the trials that we've been through
already and the cons seditious
conspiracy
and and The Oath Keepers and the proud
boys have been convicted of seditious
conspiracy well guess who they were
protecting that day proud boys were
supposed to protect Roger Stone and were
protecting Roger Stone but then then
they switched for The Oath Keepers to be
his security for that day
and we we know because uh Roger Stone
had uh Enrique atario and Stuart Rhodes
on his chat
uh on this
um this film crew caught him doing this
it's absolutely crazy that you would
think that this would be a surprise that
Roger Stone is is plotting a coup
I mean it really is kind of crazy if you
think that it's a surprise
I mean there's tons of footage of Roger
Stone I mean I'm going to pull it up
here soon we're gonna see if we can get
Gabe's inches on here I don't know if
he's going to come in at the top of the
hour
if he's coming in soon
[Music]
um
but Roger Stone if you you remember he
there was a
there's a specific clip of him talking
to Matt gatz about getting a pardon from
the president of the United States
Donald Trump
um and and basically you know thin
veiling threats that he's gonna you know
turn on him and flip on him if he
doesn't get a pardon something like some
some [__] like that right and this is
the thing that
that is important to understand about
Roger Stone and Donald Trump and their
allies does they talk like they're
they're trying to talk like they're
[__] mobsters
right that's what they're trying to do
they're trying to be a [__] organized
crime syndicate for elections and Power
and by doing that what they want to do
is they want to protect themselves so
that's why they'd have the proud boys
and The Oath Keepers protecting them but
we know we know for sure they needed
they needed a contact point to the
president of the United States The Oath
Keepers and the proud boys
there's no one better than Roger Stone
Roger Stone had had
Donald Trump on speed dial
for crying out loud
on speed dial he had them
so I mean it's not surprising it's not
surprising that The Oath Keepers wanted
to switch to their detail seeing that
Stuart Rhodes
had the store of ammo across the Potomac
we know that now
there was a stash of weapons in a hotel
across the Potomac in case Donald Trump
would declare martial law
and what would happen is the oath
Keeper's plan was to arrest the Fishers
and they would be deputized under Trump
under martial law and they would need
weapons to do that well you can't just
open carry in Washington D.C
so they had him ready in case martial
law was declared and then he they could
have opened carried
what do you think the stash of weapons
were for
it's kind of funny it's kind of funny
that the guy who was helping Trump plot
on film filming himself this isn't like
Roger Stone got caught on secret hidden
camera he had a film crew filming him
while he was plotting a coup
wild [__]
so why do you think the Oath Keepers
wanted to switch their protection of
Roger Stone instead of The Proud boys
what do you think it was about that
huh
what do you think it was about The Oath
Keepers having a stash of weapons ready
for Trump to call martial law and they
were waiting on his word they were
waiting on word from Trump
personally
hmm I wonder
I wonder what it could be
could there be a connection there
of course there is
and of course Roger Stone is one of the
30 unindicted co-conspirators down in
Georgia and my guess is is Roger Stone
flipped on Trump and all the people
because he is a [__] coward he's a
yellow little coward and we know that
from the clip of him and basically
telling Matt Getz that he needs a pardon
or he's gonna flip and he needs to tell
Trump that
what he's doing in that clip
come on they think they're mobsters
they believe it through and through and
through
now is this Roger Stone tape a Smoking
Gun you know I don't I don't know we've
seen this this uh
this uh this tape from and this is from
November for uh first 2020. remember
November 1st 2020 and this is a film
that's called a storm foretold
and here here he is talking to a bunch
of his proud boys you know [__] eat
boys whatever they are Trump supporters
let's listen to this tape let's just
hope we're celebrating I suspect it'll
be I really do suspect that it would
still be up in the air when that happens
the key thing to do is to claim victory
possession is nine tenths of law no we
won [__] you I'm sorry over you're wrong
[__] you
so there he's laying out the uh the
strategy let's just hope we're
celebrating it's uh laying out the
strategy of what they're gonna do [__]
you we won
[__] you sorry it's over
but
possession is nine tenths of the law
Jesus Christ well I mean they're walking
talking cliches right and again he's a
guy he's the worst cartoon villain that
there is
and he is a cartoon villain Roger Stone
that is
but that's November 1st 2020 right so
think about it in the context of it this
is right before the election is going to
happen they have no clue yet that
they're going to have to have a coup
attempt on the ground on January 6th
they do not know this yet
they don't know this yet
right
but they have but no they did know he
did know on November 1st
and the reason why he did know is
because of this video
this video that was shot
just days later
just days later this is November 5th
here is the video that Ari melber had on
the show last night is exclusive to his
show the beat but this is Roger Stone
dictating
to ascribe
and he's filming it the entire time it
looks like and I've watched this video a
couple times and if you see here hello
hang on hang on let me back it up if you
see here Roger Stone has his computer
here
up on a bunch of books and what appears
to be like a box or something right it's
like a I don't know a desk organizer or
some [__] and he's got a couple a couple
books it's because he's preparing for an
interview he's gonna do an interview on
something and I'm not sure maybe you
could go back and look November 5th 2020
what interview he was doing right like
right before or right after this because
that's what it would have been it had
been right before right after this
because you don't set your laptop up on
a books and a stack of [__] like that to
type
you you set your laptop down so you can
type on it right so he's gonna do an
interview and at one point in this in
this video you can see he's got a trump
2020 flag behind him as the background
and that's for the interview the other
thing too and I know this seems like
well why are you pointing this out
because it might be important in
collecting evidence of what transpired
in the interview and what he said
did he project what he was just
dictating or did he give an interview
someone told him something so now he's
dictating it right but here is here is
the lights up here here's the lights up
here and again I didn't actually watch
Ari's show
I didn't watch the show I just watched
the clip of Roger Stone
so
sorry Ari
Ari Ari Melbourne's one of the better
ones on
uh on MSNBC he is a lawyer and he does
the beat uh and it is a it is a pretty
well done show uh Ari that that is
because he's pretty straightforward he
doesn't beat around the bush much he's
not gonna [__] you like some of
these other people do uh in the media
already in [__] as much as much but
anyways
um again I just want to point out some
of the some of the what is obvious in
this video or maybe not so obvious but
let's listen to what Roger Stone says in
the video which I think is more
important when you're talking about I
don't know overturning governments and
[__] although State officials in all 50
states
must ultimately certify
the results
of the voting in their state the final
decision
as to
who
the state legislatures
authorize be sent to the Electoral
College
okay so you
can clearly dictating this to be sent
uh and and plotting out exactly what the
fake State elector scheme would look
like right they're starting to lay the
groundwork this is November 5th
this isn't this isn't December 1st 2020.
after they knew they had lost right
and they were Desperately Seeking for
states to certify in Trump's favor even
though the state law did not allow them
to do that you remember you remember in
Arizona
when the governor of Arizona did douchey
and then his name douche Deuce what's
his name
the former governor of Arizona
he was certifying the results he was
literally signing and certifying results
and Trump was calling him on the [__]
phone
calling him on the phone that was in
December
this is long before that this is four
days after the video I just showed you
where Roger Stone is telling
this these Trump supporters
just say you [__] won [__] them it's
over they can't do anything possession
is nine tenths of the law if you just
stay in office they can't kick you out
right
and here he is on November 5th laying
out the fake State electors scheme
on camera
nonetheless they have no idea what the
vote is gonna be no clue
they do not know how this vote is going
to lay out when he's dictating this
they don't know how they're going to
certify on on December 14th at this
point you remember it took almost 10
days
to get Biden to be the declared obvious
winner of the election
they had no clue
and they were still plotting to overturn
the government on January 6th
before the election
long before it not just to say oh I'm
not gonna concede that's not what this
is
that's why these [__] are
charged with Ricoh charges down in
Georgia
and the reason why is because the
criminal Enterprise happened before they
lost
they had plans in place to overthrow
your vote before you even voted of
course we know this
I mean is it hard to tell from these
[__] this criminal criminal Syndicate
of the Trump Inc
and his allies no it's not hard to tell
that why do you think the [__]
earned so much goddamn trouble
and why do you think so many people are
drawn into this
the reason why is because this is a
widespread coup it had to be
you can't you can't you can't locally
overturn a presidential election think
about it for a second think about how
our elections go our elections truly are
local in this country
where do you register to vote do you
register with the federal government to
vote
do you
do you register with the state to vote
or do you register with the county to
vote
which is it
which is it that you do
and then stop and think about how you
would have to
if if you attempted
to create election interference on such
a mass scale that you could win a
national election think about it not a
state election not like a United States
Senator right we're talking about the
president United States
think about the widespread the
widespread conspiracy that has to take
place why do you think so many people
are wrapped up in this [__]
why do you think so many people have
went to prison already for Donald Trump
and thousands more will probably go for
him
I mean [__] Craig Robertson is dead
Ashley Babbitt's dead because of trump
this this Abby Joe Abby Joe Shire she's
going to [__] prison because of trump
how many more how many more hundreds or
thousands of people are going to go to
prison for this [__]
because they're committing election
interference they committed election
fraud
they were trying to overthrow and plot a
coup in our country
but to do that you can't to do that you
can't just go nationally I mean the idea
was how can we get a focus point to
overturn this election and the idea was
just to get Mike Pence to say Donald
Trump's the king that's really truly
what they wanted
because it doesn't say you can't do that
right it does now
it does now it does now
our laws now say you can't you can't do
that but it didn't say you couldn't do
it
it's really stupid [__] idea
right that Mike Pence had the power to
do what what Roger Stone is talking
about in this clip I'm going to show the
rest of it to you here
it's really hard to watch because he's
dictating his his [__] his [__]
treasonous little plan here it's really
hard to watch because he's having
trouble thinking it through even to how
I can say this so it doesn't sound like
I'm plotting a coup
I want it to sound legal beagle the [__]
out of here
but think about it the reason why so
many people are going to prison in so
many different jurisdictions is because
you can't overthrow the United States
government locally
in one spot like Fulton County when they
were pressuring Ruby Freeman and and her
daughter Shea Moss
that wasn't gonna win it for Trump even
if Shea moss and Ruby Freeman did what
they want him to do which was get out in
front of a camera and say there's fraud
I know there's fraud I'm a lecture
worker I saw it that's what they wanted
that's what they wanted out of them and
when they told them to [__] off
when they told them no
they put the pressure on them
and they intimidated them which is a
[__] crime it's a [__] crime and I
hope even if those [__] turn
States I hope they [__] go to prison
for what they did to Ruby Freeman and
her daughter because some those are some
of the most disgusting crimes where
they're intimidating Patriots they're
intimidating people who want to
participate in their democracy who are
trying to do their civic duty by
collecting people's votes and
volunteering to make sure people have
safe elections
that's some of the biggest [__]
crimes to our democracy
but you can't you can't overthrow a
government especially the American
government centralized that's what they
wanted
right that's why that's why they they
have this stench of authoritarianism so
it's so [__] obvious
and the reason why is because they want
one person to rule they want one person
to overturn elections they want one
person to decide who's going to be
leader and who's not
that's why they were all for the Mike
Pence idea that Mike Pence could just
throw this back and these states could
do whatever the [__] they wanted but
let's listen to um the treasonous
villain clown here Roger Stone
is a decision made
solely by the legislature any
legislative body may decide
on the basis of overwhelming evidence of
fraud
to send electors to the Electoral
College
who accurately reflect reflect
the president's legitimate victory in
their state
that's not true at all that's not that's
not true that's not even close to true
that's why that's why I believe Roger
Stone is probably more likely one of the
30 unindicted co-conspirators here
because it's not true every state has
its own laws yes Pennsylvania is
different Texas is different Florida is
different they're all different on how
they uh how they have their election
laws and how they they elect the
electors and select the electors yes
that is true and some states are modeled
after other states
and his electoral college is that
something that we need to consider maybe
you know I don't know I actually believe
that if if we just get enough states to
say the popular vote in the state that's
who gets the electors and and it's
certified and there's nothing you can do
about it the certification is automatic
and you can't challenge it it's the vote
it is what it is what it is by popular
vote if enough states do that then we'll
get rid of minority rule in this country
and the other thing we need to do is the
Senate we need to fix the Senate if we
can fix the Senate and fix the [__]
Electoral College to where the majority
of States select their electors based on
popular vote alone then we're going to
move so much faster in our in our
in our long long battle for Liberty
equality and equity for everyone in this
country we're going to get much closer
to that much faster
so it's much easier to work within the
bounds of the Electoral College than to
try to get rid of it and I know that
sounds you know convoluted and you're
like well Tony the electron Electoral
College sucks yeah but if it doesn't
matter if it's if it's irrelevant if you
make it irrelevant then it then it
doesn't matter
that's that's the that's the point
that's the point
but these boneheads these boneheads
already saw the writing on the wall they
already knew Trump was going to lose
they already knew that he there wasn't
going to be enough electors certified in
states to to give him the presidency so
they already started thinking through
well how can we do this well our first
step is to let Republicans just steal
the electors and create fraudulent
electors and how we'll do that is we'll
just lie we'll just lie like we do
everything else we'll just do what we do
on everything else we'll just lie and
that's why in the clip when you hear
Roger Stone saying possession is nine
tenths of the law what he's saying is is
once it's done it's done because Roger
Stone did this in the in the 2000
election
with the Brooks Brothers Riot once it
was done once the decision was made that
not bush is the winner there was no
turning back
because they knew they knew Democrats
were gutless cowards and and they would
they would do what was good for
democracy not what was good for the
truth
well we're not [__] gutless cowards
anymore we're not gutless cowards
Liberals are not [__] gutless cowards
liberalism is the beacon of strength and
we need to [__] act like it
what Roger Stone is talking about here
is authoritarianism
that the state the state elected
officials who who certify the [__]
vote and certify the electors for that
state can just steal away the their
constituents votes that's what he's
saying here
is a state representatives if they don't
like the result they can just say well
we believe there's fraud so we're going
to overturn your vote and I'm telling
you a lot of these red States they love
that idea
oh [__] yeah what do you think what do
you think issue one was
what do you think issue one was in Ohio
where Ohio told them to [__] off
that was a [__] power grab exactly
like [__] Roger Stone is talking here
oh we don't like we don't like what
you're saying in your referendum so
we're gonna vote it down
with 60 you gotta have 60 or more or you
don't get what you want nope majority
doesn't rule minority rules
that's what he's talking about here oh
we're whiny little [__] we didn't get
our way so we're just gonna make it our
way because we're [__] privileged
little white [__] white Republican
[__]
a bunch of white men telling the rest of
the country what the [__] to do sound
familiar doesn't it
which was
illegally denied him
through fraud we must be prepared
to Lobby our Republican legislatures by
personal contact
uh
and
uh by demonstrating the overwhelming
will of the people
in their state in each state
that this
may need
to happen
so there's the there's the Roger Stone
take on his couplot
again this isn't surprising
at least it shouldn't be surprising to
you
to see that Roger Stone was on November
5th was already plotting a coup
and the coup attempt that happened on
January 6. now it doesn't allude to the
fact
in the video that he's
that they're gonna do what they did on
January 6 but it's the setup to it
that's the entire [__] point of what
how January 6 happened that's why they
were we're gonna go to the Capitol and
stop them from certifying the electors
that are legitimate because we want Mike
Pence to to accept the non-legitimate
fraudulent electors
that was the [__] plan
that was the [__] blam we've known
that for a while for a long time we
didn't know it in in that moment really
like we didn't have that idea in that
moment now we knew we knew what what
Maga wanted right
what manga wanted was Mike Pence to to
Crown Donald Trump King in that moment
but it didn't make any [__] sense
it's like what are you talking about the
best price president doesn't have that
power and they were like it doesn't say
he doesn't have that power you remember
that was one of their [__] arguments
is that well it doesn't say that he has
the power but it doesn't explicitly say
he doesn't so who's to say if he doesn't
and that's and that was where they were
going to take advantage right there in
that moment because you can't you can't
you can't rig up national elections like
this elections are local they're run
local
they're run by Heroes like sheamos and
her mom lady Ruby Freeman
Heroes those people are really truly
Heroes drawing democracy when you go
vote and you see people standing there
volunteering those those are the heroes
of artemocracy those are the people who
really who really do make our democracy
run
are some of them Bad actors well of
course I mean yeah you're gonna have
election workers that are Bad actors
it's gonna happen
but that that's the point of the justice
system that's the point of the legal
system
but until we lose sight of that until we
lose sight of what actually what
actually is possible here then they're
going to continue their stupid [__]
narrative that Democrats rigged the
election for Joe Biden to win an 8
million but shut the [__] up listen if
we were going to rig a goddamn election
listen to me when I tell you this if we
were going to rig a goddamn election we
wouldn't just make sure Joe Biden won we
made sure that we won the [__] Senate
we'd make we'd make sure that we that we
would [__]
we would rig the the House of
Representatives to have a hell of a lot
more than five or six votes you can damn
well better believe that I mean if we're
going to do something we're going to do
it right
half the time we don't actually do the
thing
but this idea that somehow somehow
Democrats had some kind of national plan
that no one knows about but all the
cabal antifa Democrats
to overturn an election and to commit
election fraud get the [__] out of here
that's not how that's why we do
elections local in the first place
that's why we do it that way
you boneheads
but they were trying they were trying so
hard to figure out a way to overturn
this election at eight at Ace at a local
level
at a local level that's what Roger Stone
is laying out here that these
Representatives state representatives
had the right to overturn their
constituents their local constituents
vote
and they were willing to go tamper with
[__] machines in Coffee County under
the under the the the order of City pal
they're willing to intimidate election
workers in Fulton County they were
willing to call state election officials
and intimidate them
into overturning and and committing
fraud in elections
they get gathered up people to become
fraudulent State electors in Michigan
they're charged
in Georgia they're likely part of the 30
uninited co-conspirators
so when you see this video of Roger
Stone understand what it is
all right understand exactly what it is
and understand that that they're they're
trying to do the same thing in 2024
folks
what do you think all the [__]
nonsense about on true social from
Grandpa election interference election
interference this election interference
oh this election interference this
election interference is election
interference election interference he's
gonna keep going and keep going and keep
going and keep going because what he
really truly wants what he truly wants
is he wants his supporters he wants
people who want him to win to interfere
in the election
that's what he truly wants because
that's the only way he's going to win he
knows it
he knows it they know it this [__]
nonsense that he's popular in this
country and the majority of the country
wants him [__]
those stop watch if if there's if
there's any evidence that I can give you
to stop listening to polls at all just
stop listening to him don't even pay
attention to him it's it's that some of
them have Joe Biden Donald Trump neck
and neck folks that's just wildly untrue
not even close
not even close it's [__] that is
nonsense that this country would
re-elect him
it's just nonsense now we have to work
for it we can't we can't take advantage
of his unpopularity we're gonna have to
work hard we're gonna have to engage
hard because there's things just as
important or more important than the
[__] than the president United States
in the Office of the President of the
United States
we got to get back a House of
Representatives if we want to have
anything done by government in after
2024 we've seen how the Republicans
operate in the house they don't get a
goddamn thing done besides talking about
Hunter Biden's dick
that's the only thing they're
concentrated on over there at the in the
House of Representatives under
Republicans is how big is Hunter Biden's
[__]
oh great great important stuff they're
doing for our nation oh yeah and they're
constituents let me tell you oh man
groundbreaking stuff really really
getting at the the swamp of it all the
[__] out of here that is the swamp
not a one of them lifting a finger after
their campaign promised the lower gas
where's that at
where the [__] are the Republicans who
promise to lower gas for the American
people if we just elected them right
remember that just elect us and we'll
make sure milk prices and inflation and
all that [__] gas prices go down we'll
protect gas stoves where the [__] are
they huh
oh yeah that's right they're they're
they're they're they're right now circle
jerking over pictures of Hunter Biden
having sex with prostitutes
that's what they're doing right now
but I guarantee you it's all distraction
it's all a distraction from their own
crimes it's all projection of their own
crimes
this whole [__] Hood's election
interference it's election interference
you know what the best part about this
is think about this
ah do you know why it is so important to
have all these indictments
and you know I I know a lot of people
think I'm full of [__] when I say Donald
Trump is not going to go to a trial next
year and I still don't believe he's
going to that's right I don't think
Donald Trump will get into one trial
next year you can hold me to it if I'm
wrong that'll be great
but if I'm right it's because I see what
exactly is important about these
indictments
it is super important about these
indictments and the reason why it is
important about these indictments
is this is the shot across the bow right
this is the warning to anyone who is
going to attempt to interfere in our
elections because they're going to
attempt it
Donald Trump and his allies are going to
attempt to interfere in this election
what do they have to lose
they're already indicted for interfering
in the last [__] election they're
already they're already indicted in
going to prison for trying to commit a
coup to try to steal your vote away to
try to subvert democracy
election fraud
they're already indicted and on their
way to a [__] prison cell for that so
why not keep going
they're going to Garen God damn T
they're going to try to interfere in
this election and try to steal your vote
away from you
100 percent
it's going to happen
and there are people who are going to be
charged and indicted for interfering and
trying to overturn the 2024 election in
places it is gonna I won't be surprised
if the state elector scheme is is not is
not indicted in Arizona Nevada and
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
if that evidence exists
but these indictments are so important
even if they don't go to trial and the
reason why is because the American
people need to know the [__] truth
and we are Trump's jury and we are all
Trump's allies jury too all the way down
the [__] ticket
every last one of them even down to dog
catcher if they support Trump we say no
we're their jury you're guilty
you're guilty of stupidity you're guilty
of fascism no we don't want it in our
country but the most important thing
about these indictments
is that they are the shot across the bow
they are the thing that protects our
democracy because it is the warning to
every single one of these seditious
[__] that hey you could try to
interfere in an election you can try
that [__] and you can try to make
fraudulent electors and all kinds of
[__] do all that [__] you want to do to
try to overturn elections and commit a
coup but guess what we're going to do
we'll prosecute you [__]
we will prosecute the [__] out of you
and that is why it is so important it's
not so important that he goes to trial
before the election I know that I know
people aren't gonna like when I say that
but that's not the important part the
important part is that we show them
there will be [__] account
accountability if you try to commit a
coup
um I I Gabe the the video of the [__]
around find out guy always comes to mind
when I start talking about that if you
[__] around you [__] around you want to
find out right do you have your mic do
you have your yeah
you [__] around yeah you're gonna find
out
wow yeah so so I I was I've been talking
about Roger Stone today for obvious
reasons
um you know I I think again uh certainly
honest I think the most significant
thing of this is he was saying this on
November 5th
right yeah like if you put it in the
context of time like this wasn't
December 13th like right before the
state yeah they knew exactly what they
were they're like they're like yeah
they're like plan a we win the election
Plan B we try to overturn the election
results they had everything ready and
there you and that shows you how
how like
uh confident and cocky and uh just
overall sure of themselves that they
were going to be able to do this with no
problem that he in front of
a documentary filmmaker
is openly saying this plan
right like the idea that he was like oh
yeah I'm just gonna say like it is no
big deal like it's gonna happen
and we're gonna be fine and we're gonna
be able to do exactly what we want here
we're gonna be able to take this
election
and have the results that we want
and as a result I could say whatever I
want on this on this little movie this
little moving picture that you boys are
making
because as a Monopoly man I feel like
that's what he would say he'd be like oh
man you guys are making this moving
picture
you said moving picture is that what you
said yeah Monopoly man says moving
picture oh is that is that tell me tell
me Roger Stone doesn't look like the
Monopoly man reincarnate it well I was
saying embodiment
yeah you could do penguin too that's
fine I mean like he's an evil character
like that I don't know if he likes fish
or not but you know that's a thing
he looks like he could yeah you know do
you know what else looks like a super
villain
um
yeah Seb Gorka there's apparently a uh a
remix I want to know I want to know
where where he made these did he make
this in mid-journey if you're
I think small rants is here it's small
right if you're in the chat did you did
you make this in mid-journey are you
making it something else
everyone's gotta go
um follow small rats when he makes these
uh Sanchez videos but this is a remix
let's let's uh it's a remix of a remix
it is a remix of a remix but let's let's
take a watches
[Music]
with this guy with the last name Sanchez
who hit this guy with the last name
Sanchez
I just want to find 11 780 votes that's
like saying I just want to have vanilla
ice cream
let's name Sanchez
Sanchez
it's not a crime to say I just want
something
as everyone knows Seb Gorka in a Twitter
space one time uh he was really pissed
off at you he was it was really Maddie
and this wasn't the first time
I you know I'm I'm uh as of yesterday
I'm tacking on these these Traders
because these Traders are so tough Tony
they are so tough
they are so Alpha really they are so
strong in there
and then in themselves they are they are
so absolutely
indestructible
that anyone who says anything to them
that they don't like
they just can't stand it well they can't
take it and yesterday yesterday
our boy Jeffrey Clark the man many know
to be in his driveway with no pants on
and only boxes and a shirt one ass can I
get some pants they said no
he tweeted that there were NPCs and
other people that were that were uh
coming after him online there were
attackers who is Jeffrey Clark no no I
mean who's coming after him oh I don't
know he said witches here let me witches
yes witches which is an NPCs and here's
the full here's the actual tweet because
there's a before and there's an after
and I literally texted you yesterday and
I said how long
before he blocks me and it was less than
24 hours later
so Jeffrey Clark
tweeted today's witch's Spirits mediums
those with spirit animals and Ukrainian
NPCs resumed their attacks on me
and I said did you find a pair of pants
for your arraignment in Georgia
wait wait wait wait wait was he looking
for a pair of pants I see I really look
I gave Jeffrey Clark the benefit of the
doubt the other day and I said look I
think maybe Jeffrey Clark puts his pant
hangs his pants up when he's lounging so
he doesn't have creases in them like on
Seinfeld on that famous episode and the
one part that I didn't put in here is I
I wanted to start with I know a mug shot
is from the chest up right but did you
find a pair of pants for your
arraignment because he's gotta go you
know he's got to go into the courtroom
he's got to speak with the judge and I
gotta the whole dog and pony show there
and I texted you yesterday and I said
you know how long until he blocks me and
you laughed at it yeah well I thought it
was funny because I figured he probably
would yeah uh let's see are you blocked
by oh yes yeah and now I'm blocked
Jeffrey and uh Jeffrey Clark right it
says how long until he blocks me and
then you laugh and then and then less
than 24 hours later wow it was only
because I checked it this morning
honestly you know what you know what
happened last night I sent a screenshot
to Jeffrey Clark I'm like hey man he
really wants you to block him
he really wanted you to block him oh boy
but these I mean dude Mega these
Republicans are so
so Alpha so strong so powerful so oh oh
you can't touch
uh Jeffrey Clark yeah dude I got it
under under my list right now I've got
at one point I had Rudy Giuliani and
then he came back and unblocked me
yeah
and then he unblocked me so I had Rudy
Giuliani for a minute I have Sev Gorka
Thompson Jeffrey Clark uh I'm just
running through the list if I can get
through all of the 18 or 19 defendants
and this in this indictment I'll be
super happy right well you know there's
a new defendant and indictment
um a new Trump supporter an indictment
This truly is a [__] around find out
this this this
um mugshots dot Zone this
this lady holy actual [__] let me tell
you something
so I can't figure out which mug shot is
the most recent mug shot she's got so
many of them
did you know that I did not know that
yeah okay so here's here's a um here's
like a a Facebook
uh thread and people are boasting here
it is you see Abigail schreier Abby Joe
is her name and she's talking she's
talking crazy [__] and she's talking to
a few people in this chat and she she
says this she typed this in this is not
me saying this she typed this in she
says I'm batshit crazy now yeah no [__]
Sherlock I thought Obama was the
Antichrist and I thought kobit was
funded by Obama I was silenced and
called a racist and phobic or whatever
and for two years I went crazy under the
guise of trust science what I do not
trust science and any lunacy of democrat
government I'm firmly planted in the
Maga Camp as I've been since 2015. oh so
she's been she's been brainwashed for a
while oh yeah of course Michael here he
hasn't been reading her Facebook post
apparently he's like I doubt of your bat
[__] crazy really Michael really do you
do you that do you doubt I don't know
man but she says she follows it up
really quickly I am crazy
I'm a terroristic threat to Austin Texas
she's typing this [__] in on Facebook
she says I'm out on bond for it so
apparently according to Abigail here she
is out on bond currently for threatening
Austin Texas which if you don't know
Austin is the capital of Texas
what the [__] is going on man uh is this
like is this real or is this like
aspirational I don't know it says at at
worst it was an empty threat
she's saying she threatened empty threat
at best I'm a snitch and they owe me a
check Communists aren't the brightest
Among Us so like
how dumb are you to to charge me an out
on bond for threats towards Austin Texas
every every one of these Republicans
every one of these Maga you know
domestic terrorists they go up to the
Capitol they take their own photos they
post their personal accounts they show
their ID badges they get upset and
confused when FBI shows up to their door
you've got a Maga Terrace who tries to
take out Biden last week he posts on on
on on [__] Facebook and says FBR
you're still watching my account because
I'm coming after Biden and then you've
got this deranged psychopath being like
I'm a I'm a terroristic threat I'm on
bond like dude
watch Michael's flip here because before
she said all that he's like I doubt if
you're batshit crazy then he says hmm
interesting I didn't know all this yeah
you are a [__] lunatic it's basically
what Michael says here and then then she
goes on this tirade again hmm Soros
funded DA's and Travis Baxter and Fort
mint County so now all of a sudden now
all of a sudden all the DA's are after
her because their sorrows funded not
because I mean threatens people not
because she's threatening people no Tony
that Line's up I mean you know look it's
one thing to threaten people
and it's like whatever what's the big
deal uh but it's another one when the
DA's are coming after you and I look at
her and I'm like yeah you are so much of
a threat
you're so badass you're so tough that
all the DA's like we gotta silence
Abigail cause she's [__] crazy and
she's about to leak all the Deep State
records and the secrets well not only
that she says hmm Bill Gates Cricket
Farm in Austin and Ottawa oh you can't
talk about that what the [__] what in
the actual [__] so she's talking about
so she's here's what she's saying she's
saying that her threats uh Gabe Gabe got
kicked her threats she's saying her
threats uh
oh
what what the hell did you do Abigail
she cut me off oh I see I see it was
probably the cricket farms we're talking
about the cricket farms so that you
can't talk you can't talk about that so
that's why we got kicked off but no what
the [__] is the cricket farms what is
this [__] lunacy it's the
do you remember I think it was maybe
last year there was all these
conspiracies about Bill Gates owning
land
well yeah he does own a lot of Landing
he's brought up a lot of land so uh
there are two there are two things one
is I believe that it has to do with that
but then also there's this whole thing
if I remember correctly was about Bill
Gates saying he likes to eat crickets to
stay healthy or something like [__] like
that I don't know but there's a big
thing where he's trying he's trying to
prevent Farmers to farm beef
is what he's trying to do if he buys up
enough grazing land and they can't Farm
beef so then they have to buy his his
artificial beef product or some [__]
crazy ass [__] just like he's gonna give
you 5G and put the [__] chip in you
even though they're like elon's chip
good Bill Gates fake chip that doesn't
really exist his conspiracy theory bad
but the real Chip that they want to put
in your brain yeah I want to go for that
one no it's because it is it has to do
so it's it's both things but mainly it's
the fact that there was a post that went
around and it has to do with the fact
that he invested money to establish a
commercially viable business for
sustainable insect production for food
and feed products in east in Central
Africa uh he also invested money I mean
like because this is also what does this
have to do with him taking over the
world again how are they turning this in
him it's because it's through his
foundation with the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation
um okay so so what I'm gathering here
from just what you're saying is that
he's investing in cricket farms to feed
food food so that he can feed human
beings is that am I getting that right
yeah they're just working on
sustainability and they're trying to
find ways to increase is that is hunger
but also to make sure that certain
insect populations don't go away you
know well right well because a lot of
those insect populations are probably
responsible for I don't know uh there's
almost like production of food there's
almost like a food
chains science is weird it's really
weird it's like um almost like we know
some of it uh already I don't know if we
do know all of it yeah well and it could
be and it could be that we just have um
hypotheses and and that sometimes
they'll change like we'll find out new
information and we're like hey we didn't
know that now that we know this piece of
information it's almost like that
happens in science or something when she
says hey I'm crazy and we go well I
already kind of knew that right well no
Michael's like really I don't think
you're crazy and she's like well listen
to this type of crazy he's like yes now
that I know that now that I have that
piece of information now that I have
that piece of information now I know
that you're crazy he's like I don't know
if you should have posted that one
though right right right you're right so
here's the headline Texas woman charged
with threatening to kill judge
overseeing Trump case and she threatened
to kill a democratic congresswoman
Abigail Joe abbaju abbaju is it is it uh
I thought her middle name would be meth
could be going on
yeah
I don't know and she's of Alvin Texas
She's accused of threatening and harming
a U.S District Judge Tanya chetkin the
one that is not just any U.S District
okay this isn't like the one overseeing
the Trump game yeah the one who hap well
one of the many that are overseeing a
trip case right right right and also
representative Sheila uh Jackson Lee I
wonder why that could be I wonder why
she threatened her what it could it be
what could be the time be but here's the
thing is that here's what she did
it's [__] bonehead called and left
messages
threatening to kill the judge if Trump
didn't win as if this is the craziest
part to me like she's not like hey I
want to take your life because you're
overseeing the court case that could put
Trump in prison she literally says in
the message if Trump doesn't win I'm
going to you know execute you that's
basically what she's saying that she's
going to take the judge's life if Trump
doesn't win as if like the judge has the
ability to make sure Trump wins or some
[__] this is the [__]
delusion that these people live in
it truly is um here's the um here's the
actual wait I do want to hold on Loki
brings up a good point
these people won't eat insects but they
will drink their own urine
you know it makes it makes a lot of
sense that's science too you know what I
mean oh that's a magnomics for you right
right well yeah yeah we do the math we
do the Maga it's magology okay
smack out meganomics is different yeah
that's different megastronomy right well
there's his mag astronomy yeah yeah
there's all the magas there's all of
them including the one where you get
your ass in federal court for
threatening to kill a judge here's
here's her here's a criminal complaint
did she okay wait hold on did she make
the empty so when she was saying there
was an empty threat was that the empty
threat that she's talking about and if I
caught up with her well I think she's
talking about empty threats that she's
made towards the capital in Austin
I think I think lady is uh you know she
she's very she's a threat professional I
mean I mean they did in Texas in Texas
they did have the big banner at the CPAC
it said we are all domestic terrorists
and apparently Abby took him seriously
she's like yeah we are okay that's fine
I'll just uh call in Terrorist Threats
we'll do that because uh in the in the
criminal complaint here it says a
complaint in this case states that the
following is true based on knowledge and
belief on or before the dates of August
5th
and she's being charged with
transmission and Interstate or foreign
Commerce of any communication containing
a threat to injure uh the person of
another so that's where she's so that's
where she's being charged with this I
don't know people think they can they're
like hey I could say this thing because
there's no law against it that's freedom
of speech right that's my First
Amendment right that's exactly right
because all I can art I can already hear
it I can already hear because remember
Craig Craig Robertson they were like oh
they killed him over his freedom of
speech no they killed him because he
made threats in a specific way
when they and then when they showed up
the service search warrant he started
firing at them so they fired back like
it's that complicated things look if
there was a way
my freedom of speech
these bullets these bullets have my you
know like [__] it's describing words
on them yeah each bullet has one word
um but if it were my weight it reminds
me of the shirt and and Happy Gilmore
you know the big guy the the the boss of
his crew where he gets he shoots him in
the head with a nail and then he comes
to his his golf tournament says guns
don't kill people I kill people
it makes me it makes me think that well
now I totally blanket First Amendment
right bullets guns oh oh
um
no I I lost it no no First Amendment
First Amendment they were gonna scribe
words on the bullets no it was before
that it was first amendment that came to
his house
yeah they fired at him because he fired
at them
oh oh
no no
God damn it Tony don't interrupt me man
I had this train of thought it happens
it happens here's here's more the
affidavit uh oh affidavits who Josh
Henry of the United States Department of
Homeland Security better Protection
Services being duly sworn to hereby
swear and affirm that the following
facts are being true to best of my
knowledge uh it goes on to say that he's
a special agent working with FPS and for
approximately 14 years and he's
investigating these violations into the
federal code now what apparently
happened is is they went to her house to
ask her about these threats and she's
like yeah [__] you apparently I don't
know now she didn't do what Craig
Robinson didn't get her guns out but
shoot me you know hey I want you to kill
me you know I dare you right will you do
it and they're like yeah we will you
made threats and then you came out guns
blazing what the [__] you want us to do
but she admitted apparently to the
agents there that yeah she those were
that was her calling yep I called and
made those threats she damn right I did
and they're like okay well then now we
have to arrest you and Charlie I mean
you even if she was like even if she was
like I didn't make those threats to be
like well someone in this house we know
at this time this is IP address
we've been you know we've been
surveilling your house we know it's you
we know you open up your laptop your
[__] Dell laptop PC
and Tracy here was saying was Judge yeah
it was Judge Chuck that was threatened
and not only judge checking but
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee
um yeah which again are both violations
of Title 18 U.S code section
875c if you can look at can you look up
and see
um what Title 18
Title 18 U.S code section 875c can you
see what the penalty the maximum
see what the maximum penalty is for that
Interstate Communications U.S law
whoever transmits shall be fined or
imprisoned
communication any threat or kidnap any
person or any threat to injure any
person of another shall be fined under
this title or imprisoned not more than
five years or both so so up to five
years is what this holds however which
one you see yes c yeah that's c yeah
yeah B if you want B
which is whoever with intent to extort
from any person then with those
conditions then you get up to 20 no more
than 20 years how many how many times do
you think Trump's gonna commit B here in
the next year and a half
[Music]
how many how many superseding
indictments for Crime that he hasn't
already committed that he's going to
commit do you think do you think we get
though it does say whoever was at the
intent to extort of any person firm
Association or Corporation any money or
anything of value transmits an
interstate or foreign Commerce any
communication containing any threat to
into the property reputation of the
addressee or of another early reputation
of a deceased person or of any threat to
accuse the addressee of any person or
crime shall be fined under this title or
in prison not more than two years so
there's ever ever it goes from two years
to five years and then there's like two
A and B are 20 years
hmm so and they both deal with
kidnapping so
um the uh the Mike Lindell Fest is going
on down in Springfield Missouri
well it is sort of so I know I'm going
to end up covering Mikey did you have a
did you have a favorite clip you want to
show today because I I want to show uh I
haven't I haven't even watched them all
yet because there was a part of me that
wanted to wait until both days because
it's only like two days right it's only
yesterday and today I I mean I hope it
lasts forever to be quite honest with
you I mean
I mean hey I want it to last three or
four weeks you know what I mean now
apparently this is the information
that's come coming out of this uh I
don't know what the hell you call it
um Mike Lindell [__] supposedly whatever
the hell I mean it it's called it you
know what it's called hmm it's called
the big flop the big the big flop I'm
calling it the big flop Summit the big
flopperoo yeah said a lot of palooza
floppapalooza Flava Palooza
oh well you know it's a flop when
they're on the uh they're on the rumble
Channel look at this [__]
1478 we get more people watching our
show every single every single day than
what Mike Lindell has watching we've got
almost 2 200 people watching right now I
know didn't he didn't he say like didn't
he say there's gonna be like hundreds of
millions of people around the world are
going to watch this thing or something
he said that for sure uh he said that
there it was gonna change the game but
mind you this is Michael Lindell who
also said that the Supreme Court was
going to issue a 9-0 ruling in favor of
Donald Trump I thought they did it as
president
it was a 9-0 ruling that they didn't
even want to look at this [__]
they were like yeah you can [__] off
yeah we're not even gonna look look most
of us on this thing are corrupt as [__]
but we're not even gonna touch this you
know what like unless you've got a
billionaire that's gonna you know cough
up some money for us we're not taking a
[__] peek at it Mike I'm not usually
a [__] like this but I'll tell you what
I'll do buddy I'll tell you what I do
since you can't get 1500 people to watch
on your Rumble Channel here's what I do
you give me some of that pillow money
all right give me some of that pillow
money and I'll simulcast I'll simulcast
your dumb ass on our channel here if
that's what you want to do that that way
you get a few more viewers just a couple
more you can over double your viewership
if you want to do that just give me some
of your pillow money I'm not usually a
[__] like that but I'll I'll
we got more people right now on our
YouTube channel viewing this exact show
where I'm showing you that he is a big
palooza down there in Springfield
Missouri what a joke now folks a lot of
people have asked me hey Tony what do
you think about
um Trump's little
um evidence thing on Monday I'm like you
know that it's based on the Mike Lindell
stuff right like that's the evidence
that he's going to bring yes yes yes
I am excited about it to be quite honest
I can't I can't wait dude we're gonna
make like three days worth of content
off this thing dude probably have at
least two or three what was that it's
just one the thing here's and here's the
thing so I made it I finished uh what
was that on uh and it's it's a live for
the for the uh patreon members that are
part of my patreon and it's on the the
fourth indictment and it covers some of
the people but in that video I was like
I'm gonna have to make several episodes
to cover the nuances and the characters
and the reactions I've got one on Rudy
Giuliani that's coming out I've got one
on Mike Lindell that's going to be
coming out
um you know it's I was gonna do one on
Hillary Clinton because they all got
[__]
in their fields and like oh she's
laughing at us that's not funny
um I might still do that but I might not
uh but yeah there's I might I think
another one too is like even though even
though Donald Trump is very upset that
Fox News keeps
continuing
to post photos that he doesn't like they
are running point for him they are yeah
did he really did he really send that on
true social he was butt hurt over the
picture that they put out yeah that was
what I saw this morning okay well let's
pull that up I'm gonna show you this is
like the first minute of the of
floppapalooza here uh down in
Springfield Missouri for Mike Lindell
this is like the first minute watch this
this apparently he can't get the video
going or it's the wrong video or
something let's watch
this historical election Summit is so
important that it's being broadcast
around the world in 85 languages on
frankspeast.com no it's not no no it's
not
the selection Summit is not going to be
about more evidence we have enough
evidence evidence has been the easy part
but what what I I hate to jump over you
but what was that did he just say that
did he just say this is not about
evidence that we already have the
evidence is that what he said
yeah I think that's what he said have we
seen this evidence yet we have not seen
this evidence and the last time he made
a claim like this he offered a five
million dollar bet
did he lose it within hours he lost that
bet to a trump supporter nonetheless to
a trump supporter and then they went to
court and then the judge was like yeah
man you owe him five million bucks you
went on you went on shows and you put
this bet out there like it was a real
thing and he proved you wrong
and you have to pay him that's you
[__] around and now you found out well
let's let's watch him find out here at
the uh floppapalooza let's see what
happens here
this Summit is all about Hope and the
plan to secure our elections immediately
steal our elections immediately did you
hear how big the crowd is did you hear
that I could I could hear a clap tens of
people are there apparently not so
there's so there's gazillions watching
around the world and 35 000 different
languages but there's also a very huge
the biggest diverse crowd you've ever
seen in your life
apparently live it's just none of them
know how to clap or cheer it's only a
few of them oh my God he's such an idiot
I want you to watch this video and see
if you all remember okay let's yeah
let's see
this is
uh
what else is coming
oh I'm gonna come I'm gonna come this is
like that moment when someone's like all
right pull up the project on the screen
and then you open the browser and it's
like
and it's the it's the intro for porn up
you know all right
go go go
es it's the wrong word oh that's the
wrong video that's not the right one I I
don't know how that got on there and the
funny part is the entire crowd all all
15 of them are laughing at him and you
can hear him in the background they're
all like all 15.
this is the exact
thing if not funnier that happened in
2021 when he had the Cyber Symposium it
was like Frank speech.com Frank
speech.com it's gonna be the best thing
ever Frank speech.com we're going to
show you how they stole the election
we've got all the data we're gonna have
a 9-0 ruling in the Supreme Court
and then it didn't and then it didn't it
didn't have any of that it didn't have
any of that and even people who were
brought in on a on a Google on a Google
Hangout were like they were like this
this doesn't make any sense it was it
was Watkins that was like every time
like I can't say anything my attorney
told me not to say anything it's like
every time this is brought up you keep
you keep having some technical
difficulty it's like oh or you play some
video or whatever it is and yeah and
then he comes back and his eye and he's
like I've been told by my attorney
first name last name that I should not
a comment on this and that if you do in
fact have these hard drives you need to
return them into the county now well we
know we know that Mike Lindell had his
cell phone taken into Hardy's
drive-through we know this yeah
the FBI they got me in the heartiest
drive and the reason why they took his
cell phone is because he was in
communication at that same this was the
this was the original uh floppapalooza
the one that you're talking about yeah
yeah this is what Watkins and at Tina
what the hell is her name Tina Tina Tina
I can't get her last name you know it's
hard to keep track of all these
seditionists she was a county clerk in
Colorado and she tampered Tina Peters
there you go Tina Peters
um
why they're all phallic I don't know but
uh anyways uh Tina Peters is being
charged with tampering with voting
machines in Colorado
um Tina Peters at the first
floppapalooza that you're talking about
with Watkins she showed up
she showed up at that [__] thing and
she was saying oh yeah there
are the sheens and I went and [__]
with the machines like she admitted to
it and she's saying she was saying that
um
the my pillow Nazi Mike Lindell had her
on a plane and they were circling or
some [__] yeah weird ass exchange and a
weird ass interview and then Tina Peters
is arrested for tampering with voting
machines in Colorado then then Mike
Lindell has his cell phone taken at a
Hardee's I wonder if any of this stuff
has anything to do with anything it
seems like maybe maybe it's all
connected baby hmm uh speaking of
connected Grandpa here thinks that uh
Fox News is intentionally putting bad
pictures of him on the screen is this
true is this true are they putting bad
pictures of him and if so why does this
make me like Fox News more why is it
doing that it's also the specifics go
back to it yeah okay he says also they
purposely show the absolutely worst
pictures of me especially the big
quote-unquote orange one it's not a
quote dude you are orange it's not oh
Orange it's not like oh man he looks oh
he's really purple but he's born no you
are orange the one with my chin pulled
way back is he talking about the neck
Gina what is it I don't know
so apparently apparently this is where
they're posting a poll I don't know this
is where they're posting a poll I don't
know if anyone has pulled this picture
that he's talking about yet but I'd
really like to see I'd really like to
see what pictures of the photo that
supposedly
is being used okay he also says they
think they are getting away with
something they're not actually they are
they did it and and and you're just
bitching about it so yeah they got away
with it what he's doing right now is
called the Streisand Effect
he's saying don't talk about this thing
why are you guys talking about this
thing
he's only going to cause more people to
talk about this thing more people are
gonna like right now
hey what poll is he talking about Fox
and Friends his chin rolled back he
looks orange I wonder what photo that is
oh it's this photo this is the worst
photo of him no no wait not not by far
is this the worst photo actually
it's just it's just like not even there
it's just like not even there oh my God
like it just there's like no chin dude
it's a flat a flat surface I can rest a
coffee book on that China China
I got that Jenna Jenna okay I'm sick and
tired of faction Fringe doing Jenna okay
this is my real chin okay okay
Jenny
Jenna Jen Janet chin
Janet Jenna cheetah Champion
excuse me excuse me rude rude folks and
Friends very rude
you talking about my chin here it's the
most magnificent ever
uh yeah okay you know what it's the best
connection it's funny it's uh definitely
not Flappy and rolled back like the
photo shows
oh my God
but my neighbors because my window's
open because it's a little [__] hot
my windows open so I can only imagine
what the people outside are like I got
this beautiful chin here the best kind
of chin you've ever seen in the world
chin Jenna Jenna chick Nick Jenny
oh my gerd
air Maggard
ermegurd oh my God this is the best kind
of chin there is not this fake news chin
on Fox and Friends
Jesus and he's really upset about this
picture
this is not there are so many words
right there's so many better photos
I mean literally you just go look at our
thumbnails of the pictures that Dave
Sanchez catalog of Donald Trump making
weird ass faces and this is not near the
worst of them not even close we're
record we got a minute we got a venmo
chat here uh everyone they want to stand
on us but they said check skips pick on
Discord Live Chat is wild over there
don't mention me they say
so so this is anonymous
um from the venmo chat if you want to
get in on the venmo chat just uh there's
the QR I'm searching chips yeah no if
you if you go if you go to the live show
chat yeah I don't know but I gotta look
I gotta look for chips though he said
yeah chip uh skip no it's skip oh skip
it skip it skip yeah God damn oh oh got
it got it got it got it okay okay okay
so here is the here's the uh is it
Lindell I don't I don't know I don't
know which one leather I got this I got
one from 13 minutes ago from skip that's
him hugging a bad guy cocaine oh well is
that the one that you're talking about
dude the chat on Discord is [__]
crazy
it's the best [__] out there on the
discard it's where the party never stops
the Cheeto chop never stops over there
on Discord thanks for the uh the venmo
chat again if you guys want to get in
the memo chat and go to
thetonymichaels.com
I'll bring your chat up on the screen
oh boy oh boy okay so um what else kind
of crazy [__] was Grandpa posting this
morning just about the picture from his
chin is that it is that the only one
well they're amongst other things oh
yeah is he committing crime on fraud
social this morning no he's coming after
Bill Barr oh wow wow well he also there
election interference he yelled that out
oh did he yeah well that's good and then
he posted a Republican primary poll
which is Trump at 60 Rama sawampe at 13
does Santa said eight Christy at five
pence at four Haley at four and Scott
add two honestly I didn't even remember
that Scott was still running who
Tim Scott
who
the guy who lost his virginity at the
age of 30 something oh what what was
what was the guy's name
uh Tim Scott no no the guy no never mind
oh Lindsey Graham
[Laughter]
oh
something wouldn't that be something I'm
just saying I'm just saying
is allegedly right allegedly allegedly I
don't know what their relationship is
you know I don't I don't know what
they've done what they haven't done
what are you saying
uh hold on sorry we got an update on
this um it turns out it looks like these
buoys in Texas yeah these the ones the
[__] the the ones of the Rio Grande
were the idea of trump officials yeah
Stephen Miller I think that was the
thing this morning
um is it the New York Times article that
peoples are pointing to
uh no this was a this is MSNBC just
screenshot I mean it makes sense right
we know we know that he's the architect
of the separation of uh of of parents
and children at the border we know this
Nazi doesn't like anyone who isn't white
who doesn't share his white supremacist
ideals who it doesn't look like him I
mean like
if of all people to to come after other
people for their appearance or or what
they look like or how they sound or
whatever Stephen Miller is the last
[__] person on the list that should
be making those comments or should be me
or saying those things or doing those
things against others
it's
I [__] hate that guy man like [__]
that guy there there are very like I
don't like to hate a lot of people man I
like you know like I might you know uh
disagree with people or dislike them in
some way but there are only like a
handful of people that I [__] hate
and he's he's right up there in the top
five
top five not five not five well so
here's the thing is the these buoys
apparently and we got another uh venmo
chat coming in here from Thai
says Tony Michael's pod thanks for the
um
it's the greatest
she's dancing have you guys seen that
guy Gabe Sanchez
he's gonna stop doing his dumb
impressions
what was the one you were doing
yesterday it was um
[__] loved it some people are like
me
dude we only have 15 minutes like 10
minutes left on the left okay all right
all right some people are like hey you
need to clip that you need to clip the
the um the John Kennedy thing I might
just put that in on this YouTube Tony
Michaels podcast every day on weekdays
from nine to eleven
Pacific Time eleven to one Central
twelve to two Easter
how nice oh that's so nice hey look I
just gotta put my teeth back in yes
that's cool anyway let's talk about this
[__] drums in [__] on
social yeah yeah well let's let's start
here Chris Webb has a report here
um a bunch of trump supporters post the
names and addresses of the Georgia grand
jurors that indicted Trump and 18
conspirators online and you know why now
here's the thing we pointed this out the
other day and Chris Chris is alluding to
it here's the NBC News screenshot that
he has of the report where apparently
they're putting and I don't know exactly
where they're where they're actually uh
putting these on the internet are they
putting them on true social is that
where they're doing it
I think these people are posting in a
variety of places but they're but
they're outing I mean like if we know
anyone I mean there there's you know
they they put them on a Facebook and
they post down there it's like hey FBI
you're looking at this
I'm gonna find you
um but it there I would I mean I can
look but I would imagine they're dumb
enough to put it everywhere right we
also have to remember we also have to
remember that the the truth social
worked with the FBI for posts that were
deemed to be threats
just want to put that out there so Trump
posted on true social that the
authorities were going to quote after
those they fought to find the riggers
right riggers now we said the other day
like hey man we see what you're saying I
get what you're saying I I don't know if
you know anything about do you know
anything about Fulton County you know
where it's at in Georgia uh I don't know
the specific location though well Fulton
County is in Atlanta like that's Atlanta
area yeah yeah right hotlanta
you know anything about E-Town dude like
specifically I I don't know I don't know
if you catch what I'm stepping in with
the riggers comment
oh yes yes we're going back to the hard
R right we're going back to the hardar
and apparently uh the supporters are
using this term rigor in the lieu of a
racial term in these posts where they're
posting these Grand jurors because my
guess is because they're in Atlanta
they're in Fulton County
most likely a percentage of them are
probably oh what is it black yes and
they're calling them riggers now because
Donald Trump called them riggers
again we got we got a hard R situation
here and that's what's happening
um I mean they they do if there's
anything they don't like to end on the r
they like to start on it well start
ending they want you to know exactly
what they mean when they say it but
that's but it also goes to show you this
is how [__]
this is how pathetic that these Mega
Trump supporters are okay
they love to scream
my voice is being suppressed I'm being
silenced my right to free speech is
being trampled on they love to say that
they can't say what they want to say
no that's that's not true because as we
know I've had people that called me the
f word
online but flip the word around as if
they were the most creative genius when
it comes to insults ever created and I
was like oh oh that's cool why are you
censoring yourself why not say the word
that you really want to say you [__]
coward if you're gonna call me that
then spell it correctly and say it the
right way and say in all caps don't be a
[__] cuck don't be a coward don't be
scared don't be afraid that someone's
gonna flag your comment because you're a
bigot
so if you're gonna say
riggers
then say what you really mean don't be
don't be don't be coy about it don't be
scared no one's no one's suppressing
your free speech right here no one's
trampling on your your First Amendment
right say what you want to [__] say
be proud about it be a man have some
[__] balls don't be a [__]
snowflake say what you mean and mean
what you say don't back away now because
the only person that is censoring your
bigotry
is yourself and you are making yourself
the victim by saying I can't say what I
really want to say
because I went on this platform
no no go ahead and say it go ahead and
say it you know what go ahead and say it
out loud go down the street and say it
to the [__] guy in the store
I dare you I dare you see what happens I
want you to he might get you with the T
and I want you to find out
so um we've got a few more venmo chats
here if you guys want to get in the
venmo chat again you use the QR code you
go to the Tony michaels.com click the
link or just go to vimo chat and search
the Tony Michaels we've got one from
Stacy here she says as a gen xer veteran
single mom of a trans son I encourage
everyone listening to go online to their
County Board of Elections and register
to volunteer on Election Day be the
change thank you very much Stacy for the
message there
um I I think that's right I think I
think we gotta we gotta be the change as
you're saying or engage in your
democracy as I say
um we've got one from Rico Charles here
as well these things are coming in Uncle
Rico Rico Suave someone in the chat
asked me the other day if they could
call me Rico Suave
oh really yeah Rico here on Discord says
the left has the [__] fam the right
has the people [__] fan
ah a bunch of cousin [__] over there
on the right I think I think what Rico
is saying here thanks for the uh thanks
for the venmo chat again uh let's see
we've got one from um Sam here let's see
yeah
they're talking about
oh my god oh lordy
the [__] fam is the funniest fam of
all
um she's talking about the uh the chin
that's not a chin that's his conjoined
twin
yes that's nice
uh we've got one from uh Tammy too here
um let's see we've got one from Tammy T
and also let me see if I can pull this
one up it's a little difficult and the
reason why is because I get a I gotta
kind of like make it happen here because
I don't have like a thing tied to venmar
or anything so uh they're promoting
Colin Allred against Ted Cruz I took
Beto a year to raise this much but
please back him uh Tammy is asking
reoccurring role in Texas Cruz nightmare
the 2018 humans against Ted Cruz so uh
you know what I would have Colin on yeah
I would love to have Colin I I want to
say this
I'm not look I'm no mathematician but as
8.8
more than twice as much as 3.4 well do
you I I wanna I wanna answer you an
honest question here okay if if if there
was Texans right and I don't care what
you're really a political affiliation is
because we know what oh I care no well
here let's say you had two people in
front of you Ted Cruz and Colin Allred
and you didn't have to know Colin Allred
that well and like Ted Cruz like hey can
I have five bucks you're like and then
Colin r is like instead of giving him
five bucks why don't you give me five
bucks like yeah that sounds like a
better deal I mean come on that would be
that's you know an appropriate response
isn't it
I feel like that would be an accurate
response 100 the idea that
Ted Cruz
asking for money it'd be like hey I need
five bucks to get a you know to get some
gas because my car broke down and I go
well
sucks to suck pull yourself over
bootstraps go get yourself a job and
raise the money yourself you [__]
idiot
uh so humans against Ted Cruz is what
Tammy's talking about so
um thanks for the venmo chat again if
you guys want to get a venmo chat in on
the show I think someone I think someone
asked about it they said what'd they
saying someone said I have eight dollars
on venmo tried to share it with you and
I don't know how to send it oh I have no
I well I don't you just go to the Tony
Michaels right here yeah pull up the
screen you got the the QR code
copy let me well let me yeah I'll do the
I'll do that but I also put the uh the
the link right here in the chat right
here in the chat so you can click it and
it'll take you to your to your to my
venmo and and you can do whatever you
got to do in venmo the problem with
venmo
drama the Trump
the problem with venmo is that it's us
only and I apologize for that but if
you're outside the United States and you
want to get us a message
um and can't do it on venmo you can go
to the Tony michaels.com there's a tip
jar there you can actually leave a
message there too so if you want it on
air on the venmo chat just let me know
that on the dip jar if you're outside
the United States just type it in there
now it's harder for me to view that
during the show the venmo is easier
that's why I chose venmo
um for this thing but it's working you
guys are you guys are really
participating in the mid mode chat
that's pretty cool so here is here's one
more time here's the QR code boom
there's the QR code
if you want to get in on the venmo chat
or you can go to the attorney
michaels.com the link is there the link
is in the chat too man it's been two
hours already son of a [__] holy [__]
people are gonna be disappointed but
here's here's what I'll tell you if you
want to keep the chat party going go to
Discord where the chat party never stops
damn it's a chat party because the chat
party never stops comes to the Discord
okay this is because it's been asked
multiple times
because it's a line y'all want some
popsicles
just go get me the newspaper go down to
the cellar in the freezer and get me
some popsicles
get some popsicles and so if you want to
smash if you want to go where the chat
never stops go to venue I just put the
um excuse me Discord geez I'm getting
confused just go to Discord and also you
know what today is right
today's Thursday do you know what
happens on Thursday night Thursday night
Thursday night you vote for bone end of
the week you vote you decide and
tomorrow me and Gabe Sanchez will break
down the bone end of the week for you so
subscribe right here on YouTube you'll
be able to vote on the community tab
don't forget to subscribe on YouTube hit
the like button too on your way out or
the dislike button make sure to vote in
that you like it tomorrow
oh my God you can also vote on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod as long as
Twitter's still there tonight you can
vote on at Tony Michael's pod go to
x.com
it's Twitter I'm never I'm never slowly
he's slowly trying to change it when you
uh when you like share links it goes to
x.com
I can't wait just to go xxx.com
well it's crazy and the reason why it's
crazy is because everyone's gonna keep
calling it Twitter because they they
built their entire marketing campaigns
off their Twitter accounts like they
spent Millions like making marketing
with like the logo
there's a there's an update there's an
update on Twitter before we go I wanna I
wanna show you how [__] done uh uh
Elon Musk is oh well they just they just
killed about a hundred million dollars
in annual revenue there was a promoted
ad Revenue Service that they that they
did on Twitter that would say like hey
if you wanted basically it's for like
user acquisition so you as a company or
as a brand pay Twitter to promote your
tweets to get them in front of new
people in their timeline and they've now
officially cut that service oh man gosh
darn it so
I'm sorry I'm sorry Elon isn't so smart
well God damn do you think that you
would you would quickly you would think
that if there was a guy that was like
hey man I'm [__] cash strapped I put
a lot of my own money in I I borrowed a
lot of money I've got a million and a
half a million a billion and a half
dollars in interest whatever he could to
make as much money as possible as
quickly as possible I've already lost 80
of my Revenue there
um I'm now gonna split the advertising
Revenue that I generate on the tweets
that are seen and go 50 50 with the
Creator okay that's fine for the Creator
and all and not even all creators who
are verified get that perk but the other
part of it is you just killed 50 of the
ad Revenue that you were gonna get that
was already eighty percent down from
when you took over and on top of that
you just killed a hundred million
dollars in annual revenue from
advertising what the [__] are you doing
where is the money coming from hey you
just don't see the genius in his
stupidity okay
you just don't see it
oh Elon you freaking idiot you're done
with this I'm done with this Tony so how
many do you have how many what was that
do you have coming this week you get a
few don't you oh man I got one that is
that is not
publicly live yet but if you're part of
the patreon go check it out if you're
not part of the patreon go sign up it's
there that one is on the Georgia
indictment and also the response as well
as a laugh from Hillary Clinton that's
in there not only that but I've got one
coming out that I'm working on right now
that is about Rudy Rudy Rudy Rico or
Rico Rudy as I call him in the world oh
so now it's a new nickname Rudy it's not
only Rico Rudy it's just everything
that's happened and all this financials
so Rico Rudy's the next one I got a Mike
Lindell I might now go after Ted Cruz
because apparently he's decided to use
the government to investigate Bud Light
so I'm
that [__] thing is still going on so
now I have to [__] drag him through
the mud too well go to go to patreon.com
Jesus patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or
what was that show.com what was that
show.com take you directly to Gabe's
patreon this is a couple couple new
people sign up yesterday uh much
appreciated uh
uh go sign up you'll love it you'll
enjoy it there's also a Discord uh you
get a private alone as well well and
while you're at it go over to
patreon.com Michaels we're gonna do a 10
minute tip we're going to put the tip in
just for democracy today just the tips
ten minute tip today here's what we're
going to do today on the round table
democracy 10 minute tip we're going to
go over a pivot and attack
that Rachel bittickoffer has so we're
going to go over there I'm gonna show it
to you show you where to find it and I'm
going to give you a copy of it so you
have it so you can keep it so you can
hold it she can read it so you can pivot
and attack when you're talking to these
megalodites out there so it's a pivot
and attack guide on the 10 minute tip
today Roundtable democracy so be
watching for that in about an hour to be
about an hour from now we'll do the 10
minute tip on the Roundtable democracy
over on patreon.com the Eternal Michaels
don't worry though even if you can't
participate on patreon it'll be free
tomorrow you'll be able to see it
tomorrow morning you'll be able to see
the 10 minute tip on the playlist go to
the Tony michaels.com the playlist is
right there it's right there on the
journeymichaels.com the playlist is
right there at the very top so go check
that out everyone Thanks for tuning in
on Thursday don't forget to vote for
bonehead of the Week Tonight tomorrow
same time same place
surf that [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
Sanchez
[Music]
hit this guy with the last name
changes
you hit this guy with the last name
Sanchez
and let's be clear I mean read the
transcript I just wants to find 11 780
votes that's like saying I just want to
have vanilla ice cream
Sanchez
who is this guy with the last name
it's not a crime to say I just want
something
thank you